we were trying to say citizens of the reject
nation in Spanish I said it exactly right
I'm pretty sure she nailed it yep guys we
are back we are here to do wreck dose I am
so excited we should tamper our expectations
only because it's a sequel and that first
one was like a masterpiece dope amazing there's
very few movies where we react to them here
and then I often still think about it it's
been like a week or something since we watched
it think about it like every single day I
really love that experience it's so freaking
good so terrifying so Tara should they leave
a like yes and they should also ring the bell
ring the bell as always fully stretch and
watch long story sync up with your own copy
of wreck 2 available for a super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page thank you all who have
joined our patreon so far for being so punched
because of all the crap we've been covering
we're gonna cover uh you know several exclusive
craps over there with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included Tara is in here
with this the sentence in Spanish
is that the only thing you know see
thank you [Music]
this is already a little scary
oh
yeah oh this is cool we're gonna be getting
it from the like SWAT team's perspective
uh multiple angles now
um
damn this one feels like it's going to be
way more violent
oh man yeah is that like a grenade launcher
I think it's those things you break indoors
with oh yeah all right or maybe I don't know
foreign
[Music]
oh
man memories
oh [__] she got loose
look how high definition this one is
keeping One camera going or two also I'd be
like I'm just gonna wear it for safety there's
a lot of blood around who do you think we'll
see Angela as a zombie that'd be cool yes
first time you really get the sense of all
four of the floors or however big this building
is yeah it was just one big shot how do you
think
that's called a battering ram okay all right
oh they're in the uh yeah well good luck I
love how immediate this is
answers
oh yeah the little boy oh the gorilla I just
love living in this world yeah
what happened last time
boy oh boy where'd he go es
of course you're not alone
I
mean even if they're not survivors you're
going to want to take care of the problem
though yeah man don't you hear that growling
that guy should really explain what they're
dealing with what the heck is going on so
that way they know to kill when they start
running after them my entire
is it the same it seems to be you got a whole
hallway to go down buddy a little girl oh
right like watching TV or something or the
dad the remember yes and he was sick in bed
[Music]
once he turns it off yeah it's probably calms
the zombies
good
oh my God come on kill it shoot it oh my God
whoa
oh my God oh my God
he went alone
oh my god did he transform already [Music]
all right shoot him oh my God
so it is [Music] oh my God oh damn they just
answer that question y'all better go get a
Bible what oh yeah okay all right oh neat
all right
why didn't the previous medical guy do that
[__] before
La Nina they get all this information in two
hours
so it is a demonic possession that forms into
a chemical so you can still treat it potentially
this makes a lot more sense how we knew all
this is
well then grab a Bible and start praying
my God it's interesting they're trying they're
doing like a marriage of both a virus infection
and a demonic possession right I don't know
if I've quite seen that
okay nope yeah those masks would come in handy
right now guys
this one plays a little bit like a survival
horror game like Resident Evil
yeah
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
yo priest you're gonna die it's frustrating
as a priest is you really need him alive
that's one solution
[Music] oh holy crap oh no old or is this
a corpse yeah oh is that the apartment oh
that's the person originally
like how the sequel is like answers [Laughter]
that's what I was worried about don't look
the prescription bit don't let the priests
get bitty you need the priest somebody grab
a Bible of anything from that room oh my God
oh my God that's terrifying what the hell
guys use your brain shoot it whoa
oh look priest I'm all down for being ominous
and all that [__] you really gotta like
prepare everybody
this is like brand new to them really like
clue them in on what's going on
oh God are those like little cages where they
kept them or were these just air ducts I need
to know oh okay
sample blood take it
down
what's down there I'm so scared no worries
I was just gonna pop out put that thing in
a safe place in your pocket buddy whoa what's
happening what is that thing 's gonna come
through what's going on no thank you shoot
come on shoot it
yeah oh there's several of them oh yeah that
is where they were all kept is where they
were all kept at not just an air duct after
all hello
check it how what what will you check how
are you gonna do it did you bring in stuff
for a whole like what's going on did you bring
gloves sir okay never mind it's out in the
open I forget that it's religious someone
so can I burn Amigos
no oh my god really guys that is so frustrating
was that just a regular guy a regular guy
he's got antibiotics
Poor Dad he did a good job breaking through
the barrier and sneaking up all those stairs
why was he all the way upstairs
loran
Holy balls okay it's cascading on you
yeah I use it come on yo that guy come on
uh the firefighter guy
how how are they getting out of this
no oh God
oh God
this one section he's so frustrating
okay
yes it is
[Applause]
oh you're out of ammo do you have a knife
do you have a knife stab him in the head oh
my God oh my God he's surrounded okay whoa
oh that old guy yeah yeah guy cared about
his looks
like is he telling him to do what I think
he's telling him to do
oh he was not telling him to do that no foreign
Pack's a different kind of visceral punch
incorrect okay it's cascading like cacophony
of course
it's interesting how this one took a much
more cinematic approach yeah it's more like
genre heavy style but it's it's fun though
I'm having fun [Applause] okay
oh gosh she's feisty
somebody find a knife man the weapon that
never dies oh neat what the heck oh my goodness
full-on exorcism
what the [__]
[Music]
oh god oh nope you got blood in your mouth
foreign
[Music]
are we going to the kids the camera
[Laughter]
well the
flyer just catch on fire does it just gonna
oh god oh yeah why would it fly
thank you and that's the last time we see
the kids
oh yeah they follow him because he got in
and then they came in after foreign
that is the most realistic found footage run
I've ever seen
it
oh God
I want these kids to die I don't like them
at all the girls are right she's all right
dumbass oh God
what what are you doing God what a dumb kid
all right
a firefighter saving your life
okay so they do like I question can they just
jump out the window but they would shoot them
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God what the
oh man [Applause] whoa I mean she flew a little
bit
so maybe he was infected when they shot him
yes because he had blood on him so he came
the second okay this all happened
uh stay away from the window bro okay what
[Applause]
yo stop shooting they're still shooting would
this be the protocol where they would just
keep shooting like that [Applause] okay so
they're softening the blow a little bit so
yeah I didn't quite turn yet right
oh boy yep there he goes it's a nice little
Easter egg to what happened before
GPS is it like a demon lure thing is that
oh it's the little girl the little girl who
bit her mom right the one who just died I
wonder who just got shot when we were with
the cops oh the priest
holy crap that's terrifying I don't wanna
know that's terrifying foreign what is that
it's the cop right
flash of light on the face come on now whoa
oh man this firefighter goes these kids are
screwed
[Applause] that's the wrong one oh my God
okay now shoot that one okay
this poor girl has just been thrusted to all
these terrible things God
this is also stressful
foreign
like a billion other zombies
yes let him turn and use him exactly yeah
both of them okay so he's gonna turn and now
eat try to eat his sister she's gonna turn
thank God it was this kid
who's that
oh my gosh she's back she lives what
damn what how Generations
living room
how'd she live because I think oh right because
she was the only one left with that weird
Zombie thing in there right yeah it's been
but then maybe somebody spent a lot of time
passed before these guys got in here though
[Music] okay
that's right that's right yeah
oh boy
because they
were full on Supernatural
wow
no I can't oh God oh my stomachs are hurt
stash
upstairs
you gotta check again buddy
so you have to do it in night vision
I still don't know how she's living yeah like
who pulled her underneath the bed but she
was the last one it was her hoop holder yeah
somehow she like got free of it I don't know
she was playing with a necklace does she have
a necklace that had a cross she had a first
one she did yeah oh see y'all need to be grabbing
crosses off the wall telling you right now
you might be right about that
I think I think
[Music] this poor girl
died
turn off the lights in darkness she may come
on
don't worry the hell they're on the Highway
to Hell
unless you have the night vision you can only
access this door in the Darkness
unless Angela's actually dead and she's being
possessed or some [__] you know to lure
them
oh
God
everything is different straight up like a
video game level God so much of this is felt
that way
weird okay
good morning what oh my
God
you don't have an extra light on you you have
a flashlight come on SWAT guy
what what is this she's back for more
[Applause]
I would turn the light on I would turn the
light on
but not before we take her blood
exactly do you think you're gonna just get
her blood exactly like how is this gonna work
don't you think the guy with the camera should
be the one should be the one that gets the
blood like give the priest a camera or vice
versa okay
no she's right there oh my God no thank you
oh is he gonna direct her to get them I'm
sure if you turn on the light you can like
she would just like disappear would she well
no she would still be stuck in that world
right like it would be
no thanks
oh well you're in Fort now good thing she's
coming for you because you need to get her
blood sir
oh my God this is just unbearable
get your blood get the blood somehow
[Music]
oh
yeah
there's plenty of her blood like why is it
when they die he can't get it it's
what what is happening
then get the blood buddy
oh yeah all right get it girl
did you find her body in the dark right and
get the blood that's what I'm saying like
turn the lights off get her blood real quick
you eventually reach a limit and she's reached
it
oh all right girl whoa okay she's done
she possessed I'm she wants it to spread yeah
how did you oh God oh God oh my only way it
made sense only way it made sense
foreign she could just do a voice thing can't
she
exactly yeah
oh my goodness it's painful that's painful
are you dead [Music]
clever
look right at the camera yep [Music] just
having just having some fun oh damn oh we're
really gonna see this oh oh okay
oh God no I hate it oh my God
[Applause]
oh my God oh my God oh my God I hate it so
that's how you transfer oh my God
Oh see it wasn't that long since the they
came in review
oh my God oh my God whoa what a journey
that was so weird the last shot I can't oh
that was really gross that's really gross
God help us I mean there were so many crosses
in that entire everyone was Catholic or very
religious in every house and no one thought
to be like let me just carry this bad boy
around yeah come on now well dang I got a
lot of thoughts on that did you like it I
did like it I mean yeah not as much as the
first one the the thing that I knew it wouldn't
be a little slight adjustment here there you
go a thing that I knew initially from the
beginning um was that I was maybe not going
to like it as much of having the four representations
of the four body cameras yeah because I really
liked that the first one only stuck to one
POV yeah um because it it's harder to make
that and but yes I I did I did like it yeah
it was a bit of an adjustment at first yes
because instantaneously like when you see
the quality of what it is you're like wow
this is really clean and crisp sharp you know
whereas the other one had a much more gritty
instant effect you know like yeah like yeah
sure it's a news team but they're like doing
some like shitty report at like three in the
morning yeah yeah they're not getting like
the best equipment and all that stuff because
I think though the thing with found footage
is that whenever you do a sequel it's instantaneously
going to feel gimmicky yeah like of course
it's gonna be found footage again you know
it instantaneously feel gimmicky at that point
so it's kind of an unavoidable trap so I think
yeah that they had to do what they're doing
yeah so I think the fact that they took it
a different direction with how to capture
it and how to go about doing the story while
still continuing the exact same story I thought
was I really appreciated it it was a bit of
an adjustment but as it kept playing out and
I got accustomed to it I I started to really
like like oh yeah this one the first one feels
like super real yeah and there's a good build
up and this one's like immediate um just the
horror right away and it's a bunch of answers
coming left and right an evolution of Supernatural
and uh like different styles you know yeah
and uh so while I yeah I mean the first one
is just kind of this contain Masterpiece and
then this one though if you're gonna do a
sequel if they just did it the exact same
way it'd be like yes yeah I'm just trying
to do so I like that this one is different
you know it played with it it felt like it
was like oh yeah now they have a budget because
they made the first one and people were probably
like yeah of course well here's more money
like more zombies more special effects and
you can have more points of view get into
like more rooms like it they they did a lot
of like tricks I think for our brain in the
first one that played with like a lower budget
and this one as I'm watching it like it was
like they could just have more people more
things involved and obviously a lot more zombies
maybe maybe in the in the first one they might
be like you're wrong we could have had as
many zombies as we wanted and we made it just
the way they wanted which was great but in
this one I just felt like oh they can play
around with like more yeah and then they did
that the entire time it was a lot they had
a lot more fun you could tell that they were
having fun like right down at the very and
she looks like right at the camera at the
very end yeah so great and the it and I think
if you can get on board with a different style
you can enjoy it because the because even
at the very beginning when it they had actually
that actual credits at the beginning of this
and instantaneously that was something where
I was like okay this is now this is now a
movie a movie yeah yeah because they're they're
cutting to credits whereas before they didn't
have if my memory serves me correct they didn't
have credits no we just cut right to her with
the firemen yeah yeah and uh yeah that was
great so yeah even like the Cinematic reveal
they treated this one a lot more cinematically
now in terms of just now taking it after the
adjustment and and uh after adjusting to what
the style is and enjoying that and the visceral
thrills what did you think overall about the
story and and the characters and stuff I liked
it I didn't like how Lara or Lara uh kept
being like we don't understand like I was
like make these people smarter like he said
it once we all get it the audience is probably
thinking the same thing like he just told
you the thing that annoyed me a little bit
where I was like why is he like right from
the top I in my brain I thought okay they
probably have a little bit bigger of a budget
and also are there more producers involved
right now that went we trust what you did
with the first one I got a note we need one
guy who's like steaming off really mad right
at the top and then he loses it and that's
what gets us into this next part of it like
in my brain I thought that that it was like
kind of a bad note like that you can have
an upstairs team that's like but I want this
and I have the money and you're like okay
because that felt off to me from from the
beginning that he was just like jealous and
what do you mean and I don't understand like
you were like what did you take man did you
take like a bunch of Addie before we got here
that was the only part that threw me off the
rest of it I I did uh really enjoy like the
answers like you said that we finally found
out that it's possession and um that the priest
was like this is a secret mission which made
it fun which I liked um and uh maybe the only
other loophole that I was like wait why is
that firefighter taking the dad with the antibiotics
actually into the building like that guy just
convinced him like no but these are Anton
and he took them and he's like I can take
these for the infection maybe he convinced
the firefighter that it would heal any infection
that was the only other loophole that I was
like wait why because the the first one I
didn't see too many loopholes I I uh plot
holes the plot holes I'm sorry plot holes
is the word I meant I didn't see too many
as there was a couple in here that I was like
wait why is that even um in there but overall
I really I did enjoy the adventure and it
was kind of um kind of nice to jump around
with the camera angles like with the kids
and then the cops and then uh the regular
camera angle the original one yeah yeah yeah
I I didn't like the characters anywhere near
as much um yeah like not even remotely close
right and you can't help but especially for
a movie that takes place like seconds later
apparently if you take if you're watching
a movie that takes place seconds later I think
it opens the door up to compare uh in that
regard where and that one you know like they
had more of a build up to it so before everything
got chaotic but in this one it may it makes
sense to me that you don't get to spend as
much time with the characters because you're
throwing them right into the Chaos versus
a chaos eventually happening where you get
accustomed to people so you can get invested
in them before [__] starts really hitting
the fan you're like you're the you're the
[__] storm like right away so that made
sense um why why you couldn't the kids didn't
they were frustrating they were genuinely
frustrating yeah like I like the presence
of the priest I thought he he had that cool
ominous thing about him like no one here delivered
that effect even though I know they're going
for more of a cinematic approach no one here
to deliver that effect where I was like like
this is not to say that their acting was bad
I wouldn't say anyone's activist about that
everyone was really committed and gave a strong
performance at the same time the movie never
gave me that feeling of I feel like I'm just
watching real people I still felt like I was
watching actors the whole time versus the
last one even that happened with like the
Angela character too obviously where she went
from you just feel like a real person to to
okay now you're a performer yeah yes but that's
probably has something to do with the way
the movie's captured to like I'm sure that
factors in to it I wouldn't say that it falls
on the actor solely I think it's because of
the the way they they switch their genre around
I wasn't sure if the camera guy in the first
one they had a relationship right this one
they we didn't really we didn't have that
no this is just an immediate situation and
it's like levels and and a bunch of answers
with especially with the religion yeah because
I like the open-endedness of the first one
where you're like it could be religion or
it could be it could be like a virus yeah
and then the first like five minutes were
like oh it's religion yeah right away they
just completely answer it but the evolution
of the um of the you know like they actually
get to speak and then but yeah they I like
how they they're trying to fuse it though
because I don't know what she's transferring
there at the very end of the move transferring
She carries it within her the source of the
infection the Satan juice there's a word for
that um transfer or wait no like the actual
thing that she's transferring uh I've seen
in another like Supernatural I think it's
actually in the show Supernatural and it's
like in other horror movies too there's a
you guys tell me I'm just gonna call it Satan
juice Satan juice yeah Satan Satan caterpillar
that's what it was yeah it was disgusting
I feel like do you think that if they started
the movie with where we see the priest and
the SWAT team and maybe some firefighters
like whatever that we kind of look into their
lives for a moment like a moment before they
arrive onto the set to see like what their
lives are like that it would have made it
a little bit like the original like let's
pray let's let's just say the priest that
we saw him get into saying I'm gonna have
to go in and it has to be a secret mission
and how do I make it happen that we would
have I don't know that maybe we would have
like cared a little bit more that it would
have set it up or would that have like do
you know what I mean yeah because I didn't
I guess we didn't really get a definitive
main lead character right I'm like this is
the head of the cops or is it the priest yeah
right and and then they wanted to save it
for the reveal of uh like oh that's really
a priest like uh subverting expectations that
it's not just some medical guy from the last
one this is a priest undercover yeah which
was a good which which did hit yeah I'm not
sure what would have um alleviated that I
just feel like like you said the thulees like
the cop and the priest that if we had a moment
where I guess with maybe the priest prior
to him going in there without revealing his
priest why is he going in here's the story
and oh crap here we go and then we get a point
of view of the SWAT I don't know like I just
you know when you have a little bit of juice
on somebody or someone up front before the
action happens it tends to make you care a
little bit more we didn't we never really
got that which would have I think would have
helped um because there wasn't anything within
the interactions that made me and feel endeared
to anyone right or feel connected to anyone
and the first one that's all over yeah yeah
um and then in this and then even with and
the kids too we're just like bickering annoying
little Rebels so I I didn't and I'm like I'm
not just gonna like them because they're kids
I'm like now you're you're movie character
kids to me you're you're frustrated and I
and I hope that one kid dies I found myself
going oh this kid does it's really frustrating
to be around is that one girl that one teenage
girl just like lock somewhere she just well
yeah she did they just locked her I saw her
legs go into a room I thought they were in
a locker in there with her brother but then
they ended up tying him up and different rooms
so she's just still she's burned up I think
I'd burn her up yeah yep but then this also
opens the door and I don't think she got bit
so she's just like a uh she actually was probably
the solo Survivor besides yeah but that was
human did she ordered though Angela demon
possessed Angela ordered uh the the the them
to burn the building right that's what I meant
I meant they're burning the they did actually
burn one person who was like a human being
right right yeah and not like possessed because
I was like oh she wasn't fit she's using that
bathroom burning and she was the only one
that was like we shouldn't do this guys I
don't want to go in on the sex doll and this
is a dumb idea and then she gets burned alive
and she had to be the one to kill like the
firefighter and the guy she just suffered
that poor teenage girl just suffered yep but
I did I think overall though what they wanted
to do was mess around with the filmmaking
and I liked what they did there I I enjoyed
I enjoyed the stylistic touches the cutting
around uh even though it makes it a little
less believable like because it's because
you're watching like someone with the found
footage you're going someone that theoretically
the idea is someone found the footage and
then edited together so someone found the
footage decided to you know edit this together
and then let's go back show the kids now watch
a time lapse over yeah and then how did Angela
survive now let's show that first so now I'm
like who's the one who edited this because
my my head's doing like who edit over as the
first one felt like some government document
thing that they found yeah so it had that
sense of believability whereas here you're
like nah this is just filmmakers but there
were some cool things there like everything
with a little evil kids was always really
creepy and scary and just really frenetic
that was awesome yeah I like the uh I even
like the M when she when she does shoot her
uh was it was really neat of the night vision
mode where they have the little girl possessed
now that's cool they brought that actress
back and the little girls possessed yeah I
I wasn't sure if I was gonna like the whole
possession thing because they went like full
possession here yeah um but I think I'm so
used to American [__] being like zombie
viruses that I'm I'm actually down for like
a possession thing yeah I like that it was
it's Satan's stuff because the voice can can
change and like uh I guess it just gives it
a little more uh juice when we see the room
with all of the the writings of like the history
of it that you're like dang this girl's been
around for she looked 99 million years old
and she started at 11. so it's a long time
for this like possession to be there which
is very interesting versus like Zombie Thing
tends to be a lot faster this had more time
to cook I guess for the story true true so
now that was like the next so because there's
like four of them and they said Rec 4 is called
apocalypse so I guess it succeeds and then
this spreads everywhere why did REC 3 the
the poster of it look like she was in a wedding
dress did I miss is she did I'm like imagine
that I think REC 3 does take place at a at
a wedding but it's not our girl I don't know
if it's our girl is that our girl this looks
like a very different person it does look
like a different person uh yeah it's just
a completely separate couple okay got it uh
past two hours no no it's 81 minutes we're
like a two hours yeah I don't know I don't
know but yeah I I have no idea I don't know
if people like Rec 3. well it's only got three
stars so maybe not let's do a wreck four got
all right apocalypse that's almost five damn
that's high holy junk and it's okay really
that's a big jump like I don't think Rec one
had that many wait a minute there's two wrecked
three options here no they're both three stars
okay wow that's really hot well let's what
one let's do one comparison here okay Rec
one though has 2.4k votes has three and a
half right oh oh I see the number of votes
right yeah yeah and then Rec four is what
is it like six 244 people though okay so okay
those are just the hardcore people who watch
the red franchise and they love it and they're
like plead it yeah let's get it going they're
the ones who watch the abysmal wreck three
and we're like I'm still gonna watch Wreck
four yeah all righty well I don't know I I
like that they did some World building that
was fun that was a lot of fun I had fun with
that one good times uh ladies and gentlemen
what did you think about wreck two do you
like it do you prefer it more than the first
one leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe go ahead leave a like but let's
send this with a patron of the day shout out
Gabriel now Gabriel he wants me to comment
to us about how you know he doesn't believe
in God and we were constantly doing like Archangel
Gabriel shout outs so now we're gonna do demonic
possession shout outs today we're going on
the complete opposite side Gabriel Gabriel
if there's anyone here at the patreon who
I would love to possess it would be you you
know what my first order of business would
be as a newly and indoctrinated demon and
then now I'm possessing you I would make you
a believer in God I feel like that would be
I would I would be looking for you man I'd
be helping you because for me as a demon to
possess you to exist that would mean that
there has to be a God as well and so by me
possessing you boom saved your life yeah which
would then get me fired from the Demon World
and I would probably just be lost and trapped
in a endless void or whatever Purgatory they
would just banish me to Purgatory yeah I guess
back up to the Purgatory like you're out of
hell you're repurgatory it's not as painful
here forever but it's a punishment I don't
know it's just neutral ground it's really
boring there versus like hell there's like
fire and fury and metal music and then there's
like heaven it's like and then Purgatory just
yeah that's probably the worst experience
thank you so much but Gabriel I would be making
sure you are uh gonna be going to heaven so
I guess your ultimate punishment would be
I convert you into becoming a believer yeah
wow he's done it he's become a good person
and started converting people like a good
Mormon boy that's that's what they do right
they go not door to door and they convert
them that's what the Mormon boys do and the
khakis and the is that Mormons Church of Jesus
Christ the Latter-Day Saints isn't it the
same thing well some some people who are Church
Jesus Christ Latter-Day Saints get offended
and when you call them that's Jehovah's Witness
dude there it's all of them see they all do
it that's why we're confused they all knock
on the door with the book and they say follow
the book it's one thing to watch a religious
horror movie it's another thing to do religious
comedies here [Laughter] well we've done it
praise be to God Gabriel and also with you